there's a  place  for us  somewhere  a place  for us  this is a tradition on all of our movies  where we toast the fur shot and we chose  the last shot  [Music]  and i just want to say that we have been  actually in production on this for  months  the choreography the dance rehearsals  the music  we've all been doing this with gustavo  dudamel and david newman conducting the  new york philharmonic orchestra  janine to sorry's work getting everybody  primed and ready to sing these great  songs as great as anybody has ever sung  them  but now to actually bring all those  elements together as one voice into an  ensemble  it's a very relevant story  to the times we now live in  i'm just so proud and honored that i got  this shot late in my career  i'll be able to tell this story directly  based on the 1957 broadway musical  [Music]  [Applause]  i'm so proud to be here  [Music]  amazing  [Applause]  [Music]  you